okay wait i think i think
you sound different now
good oh [ __ ] okay all right you and your
wrong microphone and stereo set on
discord didn't you yeah
right right exactly well i didn't do
this often too yeah i was on my i was on
my webcam mic [ __ ] that [ __ ] okay yeah
that that explains it there we go that's
the that's the great yeah
you can hear me just fine
yep
what's up
all right so i wanted to talk to you
about the whole linca thing and germany
uh because that's really like uh the
conversation with three arrows was nice
although i
sort of noticed some uh severe some
bits of information that's severely
lacking from that conversation which was
which dropped me the wrong way because
i've been following sort of central and
eastern european politics for a while
and certain things
were not mentioned in that conversation
which should have been mentioned so
that's what i'd like to talk about talk
about now sure yeah um i'm not exactly
an expert on germany uh so i'll pretty
much just stupidly accept whatever i'm
told by people i trust
um
a group a group which i suppose you
belong to you know i guess a couple of
months ago i would have asked you to
shout yourself self out but now all i
can ask is that you shout me out on your
now much larger youtube channel you
[ __ ] animal how's that going for you
well i'm a patron of smaller channels
what can i say i appreciate that
seriously
you blew up
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] insane
i uh i know right yeah i'd i'd watched
some of your videos
before but i hadn't actually got around
to watching and i binge watched like all
of your videos
um
about a week ago i think while playing
diablo very well by the way very good
diablo high quality playing and um
it's not surprising to me that you you
blew up you put you put together like
pretty good scripts and and edit them
together in a really really short length
of time how do you do you have an editor
or do you put all this stuff together
yourself i just do it myself basically
like i i i'm
an expert at cutting corners uh which is
which works actually really well if
you're if you're a youtuber
and so what i do is basically i so my
the backbone the skeleton of the video
is
actually a a glorified powerpoint
presentation on which i keep building
and so basically i can
from start to finish i can produce a
video from like between like 8 a.m and
and like
6 p.m that's so that's like from you
some
script to first character on a script to
uploading you're putting out a video
essay like every
like week to week and a half which is
insane you know i think that a lot of
people on the left like
you know when we think of like video
essays we think of like contra like yes
queen once every six months yes please
but um yeah like we're showing
a guy yeah
it's cool going faster than that i think
but anyway i don't mean to distract you
uh with regards to dilinka so just to
summarize for chat because i don't know
how many of them were up in this arc but
essentially late one night i made some
comments about the german left-leaning
political party called the party called
de linka which literally just means the
left and my statements were i was
temporarily possessed by a you know an
impish devil which possessed me to talk
about things that i know nothing about
in a very confident voice and uh you
know i i expelled the demon but uh not
before misinformation was spread so to
in in penance i uh had three arrows on
dan arrows uh who talked about some of
this stuff um and talked about sort of
the history of germany and delinquent a
little but you you took issue with some
of that so what uh what do you feel was
missing
right so uh let me unpack this first of
all uh like i think if correct me if i'm
wrong but i think the biggest point of
contention with your original take was
that uh
you said that there is sort of this
nozzle vortex exchange between the two
parties like the ifd and the linkage on
the far right in the far left and they
didn't really exist so
like there was there was a big one
yeah as my initial impression was that
like
the reason why there was voter exchange
between de linka and the afd which is
their far right part your far right
party i guess um
was because i felt like there might be
some sort of shiftlessness
with
the very like radical populists in the
country who might have been sort of a
descendant
of the ml tradition where they don't
really care if it's far left or far
right they're just like nationalist
conservatives you know yeah and and i'm
here to say that you are actually partly
correct like you just you're just you
just weren't on the correct level but
i'm going to explain why and just for
the record by the way i'm not german i
do currently live in saxon so the eye of
the heartland
uh so you know it's rough out here but
uh i'm hungarian by birth so but i do
speak german so like i am i'm plugged
into the environment over around here
and so first off the so-called red
boomers uh
is definitely a thing that you mentioned
i just want to put that out there there
are definitely old people in like
central eastern europe who long for this
for the soviet union a glory era past
like these people are usually like very
very like authoritarian minded
um
but the link is in isn't as much of a of
an old people's party really there's
it's the link is electorate is actually
pretty evenly spread out among the uh
among uh demographics
and i can give you give you some links
if you want to oh yeah sure sure yeah i
won't bog it down by reading them now
but yeah if you could provide anything
i'd be i'd love to see just this like
graphs and
graphs and stuff
just just to illustrate the point
it's from target's show and if you go
down it's the it's the
this magenta
thingy
if you go down a bit
gotcha so
english translate to english thank you
yeah
yankees
yeah so as you can see it's pretty
evenly spread out with like a heavier
this says
so the the the right okay gotcha right
right that's it that's it
so as you can see there's like a even
spread kind of so it's so we cannot make
the point that it's like a boomer party
because it really isn't
uh the boomer parties are the spd the
social democrats and they'd say they
would say were the the traditional
right-wing conservatives
right
and so my problem actually with the okay
so just to um circle back to the to the
original point so my problem with the
the uh the three errors video really was
that i felt like delinquent was given a
pass really and was treated as this
little protest party which is you know
leftists they're silly and awkward
they're a bit incompetent but their
heart is in the right place and they're
trying
etc and then you know three arrows
didn't really elaborate and then just
moved on to the afd so as far as i
remember the most of the video was
discussing the afd like non-linker stuff
and i'd like to make the point here that
that
linca is literal cancer just like the
afd and is potentially incredibly
harmful to leftism in general because
they are freaking leftists
yeah
this i i
you can quote me on that linka is is not
[ __ ] leftist or at least they have
this aesthetic of leptism
but um and they are super progressive in
in uh certain uh aspects
but uh then there's there's this a whole
other
half of the party which i'm which i'm
going to sort of which i'm about which
i'm going to talk i feel like i feel
like i'm going to potentially get in
trouble for this you know like like i
because you know i i'm just uh an idiot
uh passenger you see i th you you're in
the driver's seat it's just um
uh i guess i guess it's my car because
it's the stream but uh
uh yeah anyway i i i i just want to say
to any chatters that uh
if in casey says anything super [ __ ]
contentious it's not my fault okay but
i'm willing to hit me yeah
the the views of adam something do
necessarily represent the user bosh so
maybe something maybe we'll see
yeah yeah so just treat this as as as
my input so of course different people
have different uh perspectives so
um i don't want this to sound like
leftist infighting as in like you know
i'm i'm standing up here and like ah the
link you are into the real leftist i'm
the reluctance no no no no
um
there's
there's there's leftist infighting where
we're like walks calling each other or
like you know circular firing squad but
i believe in this case this is not valid
because
yeah
so
you were right about the nozzle vortex
as i said it's just that it happens on a
systemic sort of ideological party level
and not on an ift link a voter transfer
level
and this nozzle vortex or like this
connection between the two
manifests itself in this in
anti-liberalism and being just generally
anti-west
and um
so
this is why this is why i worry a bit
about three editors because like i like
his stuff like i don't know much about
him like i
glanced up on his content i don't uh but
for example in the video he talked about
policies around nato
and
and um
yeah basically nato and without ever
mentioning the currently ongoing war in
donbass fueled entirely by russia you
know it's us it's a it's a currently
it's an active warfare on european soil
which is currently ongoing
waged by an autocracy against a
democratically elected european state
and so
nato is kind of a big deal here because
i mean without nato
you know
all right so it was for me it was a bit
sus that as sorry go ahead from an
american perspective as i understand it
support for nato is really common in the
europe
in the eu because many european citizens
are under the impression
that uh by by
keeping nato up which america you know
largely foots the bill for we subsidize
their military defense and therefore
they can spend more of their gdp on
social programs rather than on like a
strong defense whereas otherwise like
nato essentially like is a blanket
protection they feel from like a lot of
eastern aggression uh and it frees up
their budgets that's as i understand it
like a lot of europeans feel that way
even like fairly left-leaning europeans
well i don't i don't know if i don't
know if most europeans have this sort of
clarity about it of like oh yeah
nato is a good thing because america
affords the bill and it frees up our
budget i think it's more of a more of a
safety thing and like responding to
global challenges
but and this here i'd like to make a
note that i do i i'm saying i am in
favor of a unified european military
like if you watch my federalized like
european federalization video then i
absolutely think that that the european
army should like european armies should
be sort of consolidated into one big
commonly uh commonly commanded structure
as long as turkey's not allowed in okay
i'm i'm mad at you
yeah yeah yeah all right unless or at
least until gun is around you know who
knows
checking anyway sorry go on
no worries so um
so uh you know not mentioning the
currently ongoing russian aggression
aggressions in europe uh without uh like
when talking about nato
it's kind of like it's kind of like
someone holding a lecture about the
founding of america without ever
mentioning or alluding to even slavery
you know at some point you just go wait
hold on wait a second aren't you aren't
you forgetting some wait a second oh
prager are you high you know like is
this that kind of
kind of energy
with regards to de linka's positions on
nato
well hold up let me elaborate uh so
uh this uh allow me to read this very
brief quote this is from
the first the opening years of world war
ii from british uh so-called
uh pro-appeasement um politicians you
know they tried to
in the beginning some people
uh had the idea that okay if we just
appease hitler if we just give him what
he wants he'll eventually stop and
there's gonna be peace on the continent
you know there were the centrists of the
time basically
or something similar
and so this quote uh goes as follows
this is what mind you this is the this
is after the start of world war ii and
everything that happened before so
we need immediate proposals for
improving english-german relations in
the league of nations the united kingdom
must reject the extension of the
sanctions against germany a new
conference on security and cooperation
in europe must take into account the
changed conditions in europe involve the
usa and canada and be prepared on the
basis of the league of nations we oppose
ideas of a quote-unquote regime change
in germany and are against all unproven
accusations and propaganda actions
intended to fuel hostility between
germany and the rest of europe
this of course does not speak to how we
feel about german politics we take a
critical view of the policies of german
chancellor of hitler particularly with
regard to the domestic situation but
also with regard to germany's role in
international conflicts such as poland
or czechoslovakia
we do not endorse unilateral
partisanship and condemnations but of
course germany like the rest of europe
also follows its own economic and
geostrategic interests in its
international politics
crazy huh
well i'm familiar with the language used
of the appeasement types right it looks
pretty [ __ ] bad in high school well
it looked bad at the time too i think
but in hindsight it looks mega extra bad
you know are you saying this is kind of
comparable to the um
some some attitudes taken towards like
russian aggression yeah and and this is
where i pulled the rug from under you
because this is actually the link yeah
talking about russia i just switched out
the names and countries
and this is after the war in donbass by
the way this is during
wait huh okay wait what is the war in
dunbas
oh i'm so glad you asked so the war in
donbass is eastern ukraine basically so
uh after the it's actually a picture
it's actually pretty amazing it's
ongoing to this day but what happened in
ukraine in 2013 2014 was i mean it was
it was unprecedented and i'm going to
make like a this ma i'm planning on this
massive video essay which i'm going to
put out at some point uh trademark
so the gist of it is that um it's it all
started with uh with
the ukrainian president at the time
victor ennico which is not signing the
uh
association agreement with the eu
preferring russia instead however there
were because of this there were a whole
bunch of like pro-european
mass demonstrations you know against
corruption and everything because people
were pretty [ __ ] you
know fed up with the government because
it was it was like the bottom of the
barrel at that point yeah
right and and so this this culminated in
yanukovych actually fleeing the country
and this caused this huge instability in
the country and there's basically no
government and you know a pro ukrainian
pro-european revolution happened
meanwhile you know
one to one-third to half the country is
supposedly pro-russian so you have no
[ __ ] idea who's
what side who's gonna take what side
and um
and so during this during this sort of
weakened uh states but basically like a
semi-violent transfer of power
russia uh exploited this and of course
took over crimea and they started
funneling and funding and organizing
separatists
in eastern ukraine
aiming to
basically take over as much as they can
and of course the original plan
was that so plan a was that yanukovych
wins and uh
ukraine stays in within russia
geopolitical interest so but that didn't
work so plan b
was that okay through separatists we're
going to just make the country collapse
because we governance
um
fleeting loyalty to the country etc so
you know that didn't work so plan c
we're going to take over eastern ukraine
and but that didn't really work uh so
then came plan d they're gonna take over
the eastern industrial heartland
and form a land bridge towards uh crimea
which of course they took over with the
polite green men you know these are
unmarked military personnel who just
like appeared with like top tier russian
military hardware just like to go over
everything
this looks like it [ __ ] sucks dude
okay i knew some of this stuff but not
all of it i think sorry i didn't mean
interrupt but i have i have thoughts
real quick no worries go ahead go and
it seems like
it's difficult i think
to imagine an expansionist empire like
the third reich
in the context of
um
the modern world you know because in the
modern world like you can annex you can
annex like crimea or whatever but i mean
if you started if russia like marched
into poland i mean eventually there
would be nuclear war i mean you can only
go so far with this stuff but it seems
like russia's strategy
it seems to be like you influence a ton
of political control over neighboring
leaders until um there are strong men in
countries bordering you that are in
favor of you you know or you you you pay
protesters or you incite disagreement or
you destabilized democratic systems and
eventually the country's in turmoil
without you ever having to invade and at
that point it's not an invasion it's
like uh
you know half of the country calls you
in to settle a dispute and that
territory just becomes yours afterwards
like it's it seems like the method by
which you acquire territory has changed
significantly because outright invasion
is no longer
at least not always
an effective strategy do you but this
this can only work so far right like i
don't think this strategy could never
mar this could never go past like
it could never go past the iron curtain
it could never go past like eastern
europe there's no way something like
this could happen to like a western
european country i don't think so that's
not yeah
not without huge changes to the way like
not without some massive [ __ ] happening
so do you think
there's a risk of like
russia essentially reintegrating like
the
the the the warsaw pact except not as a
warsaw pact but rather as just a sort of
ever expanding russian blanket
no no uh there's zero chance for that
for now even like even with ukraine they
they couldn't really progress beyond uh
like the red areas you see on the map
that's that's all they could get at some
point at this point plus crimea
and uh they couldn't even get the land
bridge between between crimea and the
red area like if you look at the world
map it's there right so it this this
invasion like this could only happen in
a country in turmoil and with like
just these like weird historic ties to
russia and it's like huge russian
cultural influence there
um and um
and of course
you know surprise surprise because
ukraine isn't in nato
so the the the reason why ukraine wants
into nato so bad and the reason why for
example baltic states uh
super nato so much is because if they
wouldn't be nato i mean russia would
have done the exact same thing with them
uh because like think about russia is
some certain many people view russia as
like from this framework of you know
western liberal democracies we have our
common international framework of laws
et cetera and you know gentlemen's
agreements uh sort of like this level of
civilized into international politics on
top of politics
but with russia it's like people have to
understand like russia just doesn't give
a [ __ ] it's like if russia can do
something without consequences then
you're gonna [ __ ] do it
and um
and their tolerance for for
for uh for this is much much uh sort of
higher than than
any developed nations but anyway ukraine
was the only country where they could
partially do this
but what followed after the after the
2014 insurgencies and the annexations
everything
putin expected full on that the country
will just [ __ ] collapse because the
industrial heartland is taken as taken
by separatists the army was in shambles
like i believe
i believe when the whole this whole
circus started ukraine had like in total
like a country of 44 million had like
2
500 combat ready troops
there all the rest was [ __ ] just like
chaff
gotcha and right and so this is like
it's just like a completely decayed like
state of ruin basically however uh what
happened is that
with this with with putin's actions like
this this uh
previously basically unprecedented
this ukrainian national national revival
happened so to speak and this ukrainian
national identity just like formed a
basic like
got forged in fire i guess
and um
this like really like
turned nationalism to 11 basically
and um they they actually managed to
push back the the uh
the uh the the separatists so they had
they controlled much more of eastern
ukraine
um and then they pushed them back so far
but then russia started involving like
spets nuts and other like special forces
too
which is somewhat harder to push back
against
exactly exactly so when the when the
separatists are using like top-tier
russian weapons plus like russian
special troops etc a very good very good
uh video about this is from vice it's
called the selfie soldiers
uh so they they look up uh like russian
soldiers on they contacted which is
russian facebook and they geo locate
their pictures and they go there and
they take the exact same picture
and as they go and take the pictures
they notice what they do we're in
ukraine you know this was actually a
frontline city so
and then you know like
it's it's basically confirmed that
there's there was like some major
military involvement and this is this is
what you were talking about like this is
hybrid warfare so
all out declaration of war et cetera
this doesn't work anymore instead of it
we have this this uh hybrid [ __ ] of
like
but but this is of course this is this
is of course very limited because for
that you need for russia like for this
to work russia needs a russian minority
in the area
or russian speaking
which by the way baltic countries have
uh in baltic countries it's like russian
minorities are like 20 to 30 percent or
something
right so
yeah and those can be the cases valley
basically so this is why like baltic
countries are really in favor of nato
and
in ukraine the problem was that half the
country was like russian speaking and
like tied to russia culturally and
historically whatever like about a
thousand ways
so that it was pretty like
self-explanatory
but
yeah so what happened there basically
like
what where are we now like 13 000 people
dead or even more
um
and like then now there's like uh
there's a ceasefire
which is in effect but like separatists
don't care don't really give a [ __ ]
there's war crimes being committed
regularly
uh just just yesterday i think it's a
military media article
it's a huge win yeah it's it seems like
a lot of stuff is happening over there
exactly
just yesterday the militants captured
the osce mission like the osce which is
supposed to monitor the ceasefire they
just like they're like holding i think
two of them hostage because
the ukrainian army
arrested one of their fellow militants
sorry i'm sorry 25 ukrainian soldiers
were killed in the conflict zone in the
beginning of 2021.
the i the idea of like
the idea of active soldier deaths in a
conflict zone it's just so utterly for
like like because that doesn't happen
it obviously in our country i mean in
germany in america it always happens
somewhere else you know the idea of
having to fight that off like
consistently
is there any like is there any
uh broader effort on the part of nato
nations to address or stop any of this
or we it's i mean i know it's out of
their jurisdiction but i mean are we
illicitly funneling arms or any of the
[ __ ] we typically do when we're trying
to fight against russia covertly or oh
sure sure like the actually the us has
been pretty helpful and uh like uh it's
like billions of dollars in weapons
shipment and everything like the
ukrainian army got a bunch of like
pretty nifty uh
american hardware like humvees for
example and now they are now they are
like the army is transitioning to
actually uh
uh american like assault rifles from
kalashnikovs
uh like they they bought the license
everything so like they're they're now
pretty okay
and they they cost like the ukrainian
american they go so they get support
like material tangible material support
uh ironically under trump uh
was the
when when they actually started getting
lethal weapons like before that obama
was kind of like lim lim [ __ ] around
like we don't want to give you know
lethal weapons just like defensive et
cetera
and then under trump like ironically the
hawk did like more hawkish
wing of the party they started supplying
them with javelins for example
you know players of call of duty of
course know what the javelins are
so they are supplied pretty well i would
say
and the army is now the ukrainian army
is generally in good condition now or
better than much better than it was i'm
assuming so
given all this info i'm assuming that
you are you are um
you're in favor of nato and you're
probably in favor of supporting ukraine
in this conflict
as long as as long as russia is such a
such a
in such a is in such a proximity and is
is such a threat then
ops absolutely like
in the long run of course i would like
to see changes to nato um
as i like as i previously mentioned on
the basis of say a unified european army
and um
but for now i mean this is
you know now it's necessary i and this
is wagner group which have on screen
which is this
basically unofficial russian private
army which is like private army but like
you know does the beating of putin
anyway
it seems so [ __ ] weird that all this
is to deal with russia like russia
collapsed you know it's a poor country
it's it's not
it it's just it's just interesting to me
that it would pose such a threat to the
security of europe and it's a middle
power to this day
it's a middle power and as they say
russia is like an oil monarchy with
nuclear weapons so yeah no i i know that
there are it's not like any regular
nation of its gdp obviously the legacy
of the um
of the soviet union and all the arms
build up and everything has probably
significantly affected the trajectory
of the country it's just interesting you
know
yes yes and so here we tie into the link
a bit because um so
with the link we are we're in a
situation where you know we have we got
we got a group of self-identified
leftists who are extremely quick to
point out any failings of western
western or liberal democracies
with which i agree by the way
but when it comes to autocrats like
putin you know who happened to just
oppose the west then it's like oh we
don't know lots of people say lots of
things there are many questions we
should cooperate
and it's like dude like
where's this [ __ ] fervor that you
that you criticized the west with you
know suddenly disappears you know it's
like the west has the blood of every
afghani civilian on their dirty
capitalist hands versus hmm did assad
really bare bump his own people with
glory and hey i mean they could have
just left the building when the barrel
fell inside we don't know
yeah
yeah they had the windows open there's
no way yeah i'm very familiar with those
talking points at least yeah so this is
exactly and this is exactly what's
happening with in a large part like of
course i don't want to say that this is
the entire link and this is the entire
sort of this german leftist one because
it's not obviously but what i'm saying
is that there's like a worrying trend
of like you know where were you know
just to you know given off the wall
example you know we're all you know
we're all feminists in here we're all
really we are leader like women's rights
by the way we want to withdraw from the
istanbul convention
which was this big women's rights uh
thing yeah
so it's kind of sassy
so
is this your primary opposition to the
linka the fact that you think that they
are
ambivalent towards or
sort of a betting towards a russian
aggression
not just not just
my problem is that they are not just
ambivalent like if they were like milk
they were slim ticking around like
they'd say they would say so it'll be
like okay whatever but um
so there's this sort of leftist
conference which i've come across this
is the rosa luxembourg conference
and um
on this like they they invite sort of uh
speakers uh there from uh you know
leftist for the leftist cause
and among them in 2016
was one of the i believe guests and
speakers
alexa markov who was
the
who was part of the communist branch of
the president brigade which is one of
the separatist groups fighting the
ukrainian government this happened in
2016.
so they actually got a this big [ __ ]
leftist conference and they got this
[ __ ] separatist dude up there because
he said he's a communist and like this
is like we are leftists so we are we are
inviting a
essentially terrorist fighting against a
democratically elected european state
right uh back backed up by a and backed
up by a [ __ ] autocrat
so this is to me like this this is this
is a level of red flag which i really
you know
i
i i i don't really i cannot really get
over this
that uh there's such support for for
like fascist essentially within
uh the the the [ __ ] link yeah do you
think of course like is this good do you
think it's like a very vocal minority or
do you think it's representative of the
general interest the party because i've
noticed that there were a lot of like
especially like with online movements on
the left you know you have groups which
are generally favorable like they
generally have good things to say um but
because they're not very discerning with
the leaders they choose you'll have the
lunatics rise to the top and those
lunatics can be like the assadis types
or the you know pro-china types whatever
the hell else like that kind of thing is
do you think it's like a majority or
they're just bad at picking their
leaders
uh well
question that's a good question actually
uh like in germany in general is like
more milk milk toast towards russia than
the rest of sort of central eastern
europe
but um i've heard the the [ __ ] like
the leadership of the of the lincoln
party has said some pretty yaxi [ __ ]
stuff and to the point where like it
should be a deal breaker nor ideally a
leftist movement but like when your
leader is like
you know is doing the the assad barrel
bomb [ __ ] um
and like so i feel like that should be a
deal breaker if we're like left just if
we care about people if you forget about
freedom and all that but it's not like
those leaders are still there so i mean
this this worries me a bit you know
because
how come how come
in a leftist movement someone can make
such a [ __ ] statement and then stay
in in charge you know
so that might be indicative of
some other undercurrents
but i i of course i don't see into the
linker party but i've uh
well i induced from available evidence
and yes inductive reasoning
is not the same as deductive so uh i
hypocrite take note
anyway oh sorry no i'm reading up on the
twitter this is it yorg york schindler
um yeah and there is another guy
yeah but he's uh
yeah i'm looking over the uh twitter
right now and i'm coming to the
startling realization that i don't
actually speak german so it's not
entirely helpful with regards to
discerning this guy's political views
right click uh translate
on every tweet
doesn't it translate the whole page oh
yeah i guess it does sorry i don't
normally debase myself by reading
non-english literature let me see
i doubt that just scrolling through this
i'm going to see anything especially bad
especially because a lot of bad stuff is
kind of couched in implication
um
which i wouldn't be able to discern with
google translate uh on random tweets you
know but no i i i get what you mean you
know it would be um
it would be like having gray zone types
in the leadership leadership of your
left party very uh
very concerning
are you or like or like um assadists
basically like people who are who they
don't say that there are sadists but
like every single political position
that they hold like a geopolitical
position in terms of like foreign
relations
all of them somehow just by some [ __ ]
miracle
align perfectly with say russian
geopolitical interest you know
and um
it's
anyway so um that's that's my problem
with with the link here that they really
strike me as this like group of like
just tankies essentially
who are extremely quick to
just latch on to anything that they that
they deem say anti-western because you
know
they they oppose western and border
liberal democracies um and so they end
up in a situation where they
um
embrace autocrats and it is the exact
same thing as i think kraut made a video
about this
oh yeah i have it here it's called
embracing tyranny to own the libs
and this was from the far right of like
you know there was a there was the
women's march and people were like oh
yeah dude uh these these [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know like if if if this was in base
russia the police would have just like
tear-gassed them off the streets already
so yeah and then kraut made the point
that hey you know by the way did you
know that [ __ ] in russia it's like
it's incredibly dangerous for women and
like domestic abuse
uh laws were like loosened and they were
like pretty um sort of a resident cases
of like you know like this was it like a
russian tv presenter like beating his
wife to death and coming nothing of it
and like some woman calling the local
police that he her husband was like
attacking her and then police just told
her to [ __ ] off and then she died and
then
just like domestic violence just like
spiking uh male and female yeah uh and
yeah so
so this and and so and and this but this
is this is this is the political
formation that the link is support
really and when i see there you know
when i see their little when i saw
little stickers in the this was during
the previous elections uh when i was in
around manheim um
so like yeah still leftist still
feminist and it's like dude like you're
you're you're pro russia by the way like
did you know that you're okay you're a
feminist but like your party is like bro
russia
and like
they don't really they're like
pretty like pussy-putting around the
crimea issue and you know
so
which is as far as i'm concerned these
things are the same as like pussyfooting
around the [ __ ] holodomor or the
holocaust itself so at that point you
have to
look at which point do you need to just
like be like okay wait hold hold on stop
let's let's let's clarify a few things
because i think we really [ __ ] need
to well i don't think there's anything
wrong with being critical of stuff like
that you know um
[ __ ] what's his name guys who's that
who's that um leftist modern leftist
theorist who's um often compared and
juxtaposed to noam chomsky he's more um
he's more tanky aligned uh uh parenthe
apparently thank you i know that parenti
basically lost faith in bernie sanders
when bernie sanders apparently supported
the nato bombing of yugoslavia um
but um you know if principled left
people can't have uh
move their alignments based on people's
positions and stuff like that
i think this is a perfectly acceptable
reason to be upset but you've put me in
a bit of a bad position because uh
now that i've heard two different
opinions i'm gonna have to do
independent research rather than
stupidly listening to the last person to
have spoken to me
damn
yeah i know why the [ __ ] would you why i
already have enough on my plate okay
jesus during the
get up uh the hardcore barbarian diablo
too
do you um right who did you vote for in
the most recent elections
uh i cannot vote in germany uh i mean i
have a hungarian citizenship oh so
that's right that's right yeah you're
not yeah okay gotcha gotcha yeah yeah
but i would have voted for the greens
actually like if anyone's looking for
like a
trustworthy sort of leftist party which
actually opposes autocrats than greens
in germany that would be it
did you um the what's the citizenship
process in germany do you intend on
becoming a citizen or are you just there
sort of temporarily uh i'm there for the
time being and then i'll be i'll be back
in the czech republic so i'm
pan-european like that gotcha what about
yeah what about the um i know that there
are a lot of neo-nazis um
in in like uh in ukraine right are they
like the other factions
that would be taking over were it not
for
russia's presence in the east or like
what is is there like a good faction
panned to take over ukraine or no uh it
already happened actually yeah of course
like the so ukraine so far had um how
they had two elections ever since the
this circus started and during the in
the first election was sort of like
born in fire so to speak so at that
point people just elected whoever the
[ __ ] like whoever the [ __ ] was
pro-european and anti-russia and that
man was petro poroshenko who was a
he was a ukrainian oligarch he has this
like giant like food enterprise
everything he is corrupted [ __ ] i don't
like him but
he was like a civic nationalist uh but
like he
to his credit he took ukraine like he
sort of took ukraine out of the crisis
uh in the end
uh and then
um a semi-miracle happened in like 2019
i believe during the presidential
elections and then later the
parliamentary elections
where this guy called the vladimir
zelinski won the presidency and then his
party uh servant of the people uh
lucanaroni
uh won the elections but like in a
[ __ ] landslide
and zelensky himself is uh like i think
he won like by the biggest margin in the
history of ukraine
and he himself is is
like he was he came from outside of
politics he was like he campaigned on
like anti-corruption populism etc right
and um
he actually like he's jewish by the way
so you know it's that anti-semitism i
don't think really plays part here
and um
i do this that he's in charge and he's i
think he's doing a fair enough job all
things considered but with regards to
the naughty thing in ukraine
there there is certainly an element of
that like the other battalion as we all
as you know
most of us might know who are familiar
with the issue
the other battalion is is comprised of
like his far right ultra nationalist etc
uh people
but the thing is like outside of ukraine
these groups like that group doesn't
really have a reach and the reason why
they get so galvanized and so uppity is
because i mean their [ __ ] country is
under attack so you know if you're an
ultra nationalist fondle weapons fond of
that sort of
stuff and then a foreign country invades
you i mean that's that's like that's
part horrifying and part wet dream you
know like finally
it's like the the secret thing you've
been dreaming about
and they actually um
i think thing about them was that um
they were actually a bit difficult to
coordinate because they just went their
own way kind of however
uh they played some key roles in the
conflict so um they actually
were the most like they had the most
morale because they were of course
fighting against the like they had a
clear objective
fight against the enemy etc of course
for all the wrong reasons but still
um and so their morale really helped a
lot i here and they were basically
essentially the only ones for a long
time who gained back any territory
against separatists as the ukrainian
army was just like reeling because of
this
and because of the you know like if you
know imagine this like you and 20 others
are in a room and you hear that the
separatists are coming
and you look around and you have no
[ __ ] idea that out of these 20 people
who's going to join the separatist and
shoot you in the back or who's going to
shoot at them
because it was completely unclear who's
like whose allegiance
is aware
gotcha so i feel i feel like we're so
out of the range of stuff that i have
even any even a little bit of knowledge
on that i have absolutely no way of
uh um
like i have no intuitive opinion on any
of this i would have to do a lot of
research i guess i guess it wouldn't
hurt me to learn a little bit about the
[ __ ] powder keg that is everything in
between germany and russia anyway yeah
uh if you're interested then there's
this great video series like vice news
had a
vice news head i think two videos are
like which are super great which are
during the the the actual revolution and
protests
one was i think
the first one was ukraine last days of
the revolution and then ukraine burning
these are the two videos which are like
really summarize the the whole period
and then there's the and then this vice
i think the russian russian roulette
series it's like really [ __ ] looks
100 plus videos or something but
anyway wikipedia also suffices in this
case
gotcha but yes we're reading on the
kosovo war now
oh oh god no no no [ __ ] serbs anyway
yeah that was another
you know burial monkeys over there
yeah it's just so weird seeing eastern
europeans be racist to each other when
none of them are like american
like they're all like what are you
fighting over you're all eastern
european
what do you have what do you have
yeah what yeah like
why
what are you fighting over yeah um
[ __ ] god damn it okay hold on wait we
have to stop okay i've already mentally
i've already mentally checkmarked like
17 things that i need to learn about we
have to stop we have to stop right here
adam it's all right i don't i don't want
to up uh you know overload you too much
you're american after all yeah thank you
okay we have like okay it's very ableist
of you to try to load us up with foreign
policy knowledge jesus christ
yeah balkan ultra nationalism is really
[ __ ] strange i know that gets hyper
obsessive over whenever you go online
you can see them freaking out at each
other um
[ __ ]
the balkan is a different story though
like ukraine is more like east like
russia right right i know i know
yeah russia's definitely i mean you know
russia's like a at least had hands and
stuff all around the place oh of course
of course serbia and greece yes yeah
[ __ ] okay look i need to read up more of
this stuff and then after that i'll
probably
i'll probably want to talk to you again
about it okay
all right all right just do a resource
stream or something i don't know yeah i
might have to
it doesn't hurt because this like this
this kind of uh subject especially the
the the current russo ukrainian war
uh is i think a very useful lens to view
politicians and movements uh through
because
like their view their view on this issue
can tell a lot about the movement itself
so it's a very very good like litmus
test so to speak
um yeah but to sum up just a quick
summary then so once again my issue with
the whole uh
three area was discussion which i think
was it i think was super cool and
productive
my problem was that i think that the
elephant in the room wasn't really you
know at fest which is the [ __ ] you
know currently ongoing active warfare
uh against ukraine by an autocracy you
know
against a democratic state on european
soil in 2021
like i would i feel like this is kind of
a biggie
and to talk about nato and like
such things uh without ever mentioning
it is like [ __ ] ben shapiro giving a
two-hour lecture about civil rights in
america without ever once mentioning a
black lives matter you know it's like uh
ben you know
all right i'll keep that in mind yeah i
guess it's difficult i i know that
europeans probably have a much more
intimate
understanding of the the perceived
threat that russian imperialism has see
over here it's always been abstract
right i mean even during the cold war
over here in the united states it was
more just the nebulous threat of a bad
guy in the opposite end of the world not
so much like you can look at a map and
just see the border and it's like a
thousand miles away from your border and
that's where fighting is happening
exactly so by the way where i lived in
hungary
um currently i could take a train and
like transition once uh from my hometown
in hungary and be on the front line in
ukraine
so that's kind of [ __ ] spooky
yeah it's i'm too trained tickets away
so yeah that's it gotcha okay i'm gonna
read up on this i appreciate you giving
me an alternate perspective and spurring
me to action all right
well of course of course hey i'm gonna
i'm gonna put out the ukraine video at
some point in the near future uh which
is within the next uh six years or two
months
depending and you can just you can also
watch that i'm gonna obviously what i'm
gonna do is basically i'm gonna just
break down the entire process from the
sort of start of the protests until
today to like give an overview so that
people will not be
sort of under-informed or misinformed et
cetera about the issue well i'll watch
it as soon as it comes out thank you
again and again i i i would shout out
your channel but you know you're bigger
than me now so i don't know if he's feel
free to shout me out i'll shout yet as
well we're about like we're the same
ballpark so you know uh yeah for now
jesus not in a month from now um anyway
adam something's video slaps guys so you
should all look at it when you can okay
thank you yeah thank you for coming on
man i hope to talk to you in the future
yep me too thanks for having me on so
have a good stream and talk to you later
i guess i'll talk to you soon
yep bye